what I love about white tiger is you
just like don't for any note we're like
it's amazing it doesn't even matter
right what the heck is happening there
listen that was any no and this is not
American Idol but it's a no for me dog
oh the white tiger is giving us a lot to
sink our teeth into pun intended
we're gonna get into that and so so so
much more tonight on unmasking the
masked singer but first I want to let
everyone know we have a very special
surprise guest joining us later in the
episode someone who has competed on
season two of the show so they're gonna
dish everything do not miss it
stick with us but first let's get into
tonight's heartbreaking elimination take
a look
[Applause]
dear Nicole's reaction is everything I
want that for every every response we
need that gift is on a long loop look
you know we had Patti LaBelle we had
Gladys Knight now we've got Chaka Khan
it just is a testament to this show and
how powerful it is that these are
legends among us truly these women are
so iconic they've got the vocals to back
it up and and what a treat to have
someone like Chaka Khan on this season
insanely and what gave it away for you I
know we saw a few more clues tonight
that really solidified that it was Chaka
Khan yeah what were you getting okay a
couple of things if we want to kind of T
up the clue package here we saw the
months the Miss Monster looking at I'm
sorry that's that's her friend the
hairstylist so this week they did
something a little different they
invited on friends and family members so
Miss Monster invited her hairstylist and
here he is kind of examining on a piece
of pizza some white socks and I'm just
like wait what is going on so let's talk
about the pizza first there is a song
that Chaka Khan did called all good with
De La Soul and and the lyrics are
actually quite funny it's all about kind
of building a pizza and a lot of using
the word pepperoni in a song I mean we
just kind of loved it then you want to
talk about the two white socks it's not
that deep it's literally the white socks
as in the Chicago White Sox and we also
saw a teddy bear
so white socks bear mm-hmm Chicago pride
obviously Chaka Khan is from Chicago so
that makes all the sense in the world
and the last clue that really kind of
gave it away was the camo print we saw
there it is we saw some like camo
t-shirts and some other things kind of
hanging on the on the wire their
camouflage is an album title of the funk
band Rufus featuring Chaka Khan okay so
I think these clues are definitely
harder than last season it took a second
for me to like let it digest inside my
brain but ultimately they all pointed to
Queen Shaka and chard and everything we
saw in weeks before what did you think
well I love the new Valentine Clues we
got today so it was a Valentine teams
episode love was in the air and they had
the contestants read a Valentine to one
of the judges who we then found out they
have had a past relationship worth in
some way so for Robin I have an eye for
you we even had a rendezvous
in Sin City well Sin City meaning Las
Vegas Chaka Khan and Robin Thicke have
performed in Las Vegas together in 2009
they're so adorable look at them Thank
You bees Robin didn't even know it was
her under there luckily he did guess
right before the unmasking him and
Nicole both said it's Chaka and they
were right look I hope if you've
performed with someone you would know
their voice rehearse with them you've
done this a million times you would hope
that that voice would be instantaneously
recognizable but you know the show
throws everyone for a little parently
well we are now down to our top three
champions so with tonight's elimination
this is the Group A champions who we
will see later on in the season compete
with the top three from Group B and C
and we actually asked you guys on
entertainment tonight's Twitter who you
were going and who you were rooting for
tonight and you all agreed that turtle
mask so you loved the turtle mask and we
should take a look at him we loved him
as well
[Applause]
[Music]
I mean the vocals everybody the vocals
give us a thumbs up if you are loving
the turtle as much as we are this is
someone who's got so much flavor and
soul and I really love that we got to
see some choreography to really prove
that this person is totally at least a
double threat they can sing and they can
dance let's get right into the clue
package if we can and kind of dissect
the evidence here so this is the turtles
past teacher so we're in a classroom
here and if you take a look at the
chalkboard there's an alpha and there's
an Omega so I was like was the turtle in
a fraternity I was like thinking all
these different Greek clues again it's
not that deep the turtle was literally
on the show Greek he played a character
named Andy of course I don't think I've
mentioned so Jesse McCartney sorry I
feel like we keep saying for sticking
with our guys we're sticking with our
guests that it's Jesse McCartney of
course he played the character Andy on
the ABC Family show Greek now let if we
can throw up the map we saw Seoul South
Korea yes which I was like okay is this
someone who's maybe on tour there has
toured there many times again I'm just
gonna take Seoul quite literally with a
different spelling and allude to Jesse's
like super huge hit beautiful soul the
best the song that we can't truly get
enough of such a Bop we also saw on the
teacher's desk like the Batman logo or
the Batman signal so yeah I was like
it's kind of creepy what does it mean is
it someone who's in the superhero kind
of like a universe well yes Jesse
McCartney is in the superhero universe
he voices Robin in the animated series
Young Justice so I mean do we really
need more proof than this I'm sold here
weird right weirdest rattling it off
left and right my final thing is the
teacher said I hope you have the the
best time of your life or the have the
time of your life Jesse McCartney has a
song called best day of my life so I
feel like all of these things are just
kind of stacking up at this point
exactly and listen if those were not
enough the Valentine's clue did it as
well we heard it directed to Nicole I'll
never forget the morning we spent
together it was totally awesome well as
you can see they're totally awesome the
morning him a Nicole spent together it
happened to be on NBC's Today Show in
August of 2008 Nicole the Pussycat Dolls
Jesse McCartney and Katy Perry performed
together which is like iconic trio I
love that
taking these clues that are such
throwbacks I mean these pictures are
truly so like iconic primate loves me I
feel like I remember watching this on TV
ten or so whatever it was years ago I
loved it and again it goes back to
Nicole has performed with this person I
would hope she'll get his voice in the
coming weeks maybe introduce Jessi
because none of the judges have said his
name so far no they haven't and it's
like Nicole you have the most incredible
ear and she has perfect pitch yep I
would hope that she would recognise that
in hopefully Jesse McCartney I do want
to mention there was something that
happened on TV last night that we want
to show you guys the Backstreet Boys who
you know Charlie and I especially mean
we really stand very hardcore and we
would love to see them on the masked
singer the name AJ McLean has been
thrown out a ton of times they were
guests on watch what happens live and
they were asked point-blank are you on
the masked singer here's what they said
Matt be emailed for all of you AJ are
the rumors true that you're the turtle
this season oh my god is still going on
yeah no because I'm here right now so
clearly I'm not the turtle okay well not
a live show no but still I and if I was
I wouldn't tell anyone
that being said do what Patti LaBelle
was here and lied to my face the turtles
have a confession yeah I don't know if I
can say this out loud the turtle was
created for me is that choice I was
possibly gonna be on the show oh really
they offered it to you yeah we were busy
Wow okay how do you feel about mad gasp
yeah that's insane to just drop that
yeah cuz especially this show is
shrouded in secrecy and I don't know if
producers necessarily love when people
admit I was maybe gonna do a show and I
didn't do it you obviously the
Backstreet Boys are busy there they're
making music and they're touring the
world and doing all those things here's
why I'm torn about this a part of me is
like dude Nick Carter you have to do
this show I would love to see any of the
Backstreet Boys they're such natural
born performers they'd be so incredible
on the show but the other part of me is
like don't bring that up
like just let the turtle have its moment
and like if it is Jesse McCartney let
him have it
yeah like the turtle is a perfectly
suited costume for him and symbolism
like slow and steady wins the race I
really appreciate that narrative so I
don't know kind I was just like
notorious well another performer who
certainly brought
there ain't game tonight was the
kangaroo who shined bright like a
diamond
take a look beautiful
[Music]
well I don't know
whoo what do you think it's so soulful
every week we I'm just shocked by this
voice because yeah if it is who we think
it is
Jordan was I didn't know she could sing
no I certainly didn't either and you
know we had Adrienne Houghton on the
show last week and she was like you guys
are crazy it's definitely Jordans if
it's between Jordan sparks or Jordan
woods she was definitely leaning Jordan
sparks but I think after going through
the the clues this week we have even
more evidence proving why it is Jordan
woods so her family or relative clue
went to someone who claimed to be her
younger brother her younger brother is
named John woods the third so we do know
she has a younger brother Jordan Woods
the first thing that tipped me off was
the boom mic so if you know anything
about Jordan woods she's no stranger to
being on reality TV whether it's Keeping
Up with the Kardashians or life of Kylie
here they are kind of like her brother
here is kind of filming a confessional I
can in the moment interview exactly we
also got to see this model airplane and
I have a couple different theories about
the model airplane okay the first is
that she travels a lot point-blank the
girls busy she's booked in busy the
second is that she's a model quite
literally this is a model airplane okay
and then this is the third and perhaps
the most convincing in my opinion when
she when Jordan Woods was on Jada
Pinkett Jada Pinkett Smith's red
tabletalk she had to take a lie-detector
test and Jada was quoted as saying she
passed with flying colors so I think all
of that symbolism there I mean are we on
the right track we're on the right track
especially with one thing you just said
there you bring up red Tabletalk yes
well the Valentines clue we saw here was
to Leah Leah Remini was the guest judge
tonight on the show and she said we've
sat at the same table and your courage
has inspired me hmm well there is one
table that happens to be red yeah both
Leah and Jordan have Sarah and that is
Jada Pinkett it's red Table Talk
Facebook watch series Leah appeared in
November of 2018 and Jordan followed in
March of 2019 yeah so that is definitely
somewhere where these women go to talk
about their stories something that may
be in the news for example Jordan was
going through it at that time with the
Kardashians but sitting down and talking
about courage and being inspired I think
it'll all make sense there I mean I'm so
that they were able to if it is Jordan
woods it's so cool to see her have a
moment with Leah Remini because they
aren't like you mentioned they are women
who have gone through a lot and they've
been at the the front of a lot of
publicity and a lot of scandal and and I
love that leah has gotten her sort of
like vindication and she won her Emmy
and she's like living her best life and
hopefully it's the start of that for
Jordan woods as well so we're sticking
with it he'll be next performer
certainly rocked us in one way or
another one way of putting it take a
look
[Applause]
[Music]
were you rocked were you rocked by the
weight I was rocked I was shook a lot of
questions I what do you think I'm we're
gonna stick with our original guests Rob
Gronkowski former player for the New
England Patriots again not the best
vocal prowess from this performer but if
we know anything about Rob Gronkowski
really just big performer
larger-than-life let's talk about the
clue package really quickly we saw a
knee on route 66 sign in the bar
now I look this up and actually Rob
Gronkowski once hosted an event at a
route 66 Raceway in Chicago so he notes
we have yep we've got something there
then if we can take a look at the
quarter on the bar I mean I'm no sports
expert but I'm pretty sure this is a big
thing in the world of football coin toss
yes the big thing for me were these
butter Pat's Pat's of butter I was like
does this guy like does he like
bulletproof coffee what's going on well
it turns out apparently Gronk has gotten
a lot more plant-based in his retirement
importance now important to know but
just quite literally Pat's Pat's of
butter played for the Patriots yes we
also saw a telephone that was off the
hook
mm-hmm and I was like is this someone
who like had a phone snafu or something
involving a phone well his former coach
Bill Belichick was asked in November
when when Gronk announced I had this big
announcement and and someone was like
bill what do you think it is and he's
like I don't know what it is but I'm
sure my phone will be ringing off the
hook whatever it is and the phone is yes
and I know you've discovered something
with the dark I discovered this one
pretty last minute and I'm still kind of
proud of myself yeah um if you look at
what the dart landing places add up to
here it's on 18 3 & 8 well those add up
to 29 and Gronk retired from the NFL at
age 29
I am patting myself on the back for that
one guy I'm patting you on the back of
your head and Gronk on the back if it is
him because retiring at 29 is such a
boss move I know what a legend live your
best might be Valentine's Day clue this
was a really good one it was - Jenny
Jenny I am wild about you but I know
your husband will appreciate this card
even more
Donnie Wahlberg loves Gronk loves the
Patriots and you can actually see them
fangirling over Gronk in this clip take
a look
you know Krunk is the greatest guy in
the world and people think of him as a
party animal and you know a wild child
but sitting next to him watching that
game I could see how much it was killing
and that he couldn't be out there if you
know anything about the Wahlberg's
they literally bleed Patriots they bleed
Tom Brady and they bleed Rob Gronkowski
all these Valentine's Clues are showing
that the judges have hung out or
literally performed and know the people
that are performing on the stage in
front of them that's why Hollywood is
six degrees six degrees of separation
yeah it's a small world they're all
connected some way or another of course
we have introduced a new segment on this
show called reality check where we give
the judges that we adore and love so
much just a little dose of reality and
call them out on some of their wacky er
guesses you want to take the lead on
that one this one is um shocking to say
the least I'm just gonna say that take a
look at contend guests during tonight's
performance is that pad of butter is not
butter and you know whose folks for that
Fabio said I can't believe it's butter
it is right there in the clue package
these are giant presents who's looking
to rebrand themselves
ever since that unfortunate roller
coaster in Sid where that bird just hit
him in the face
you come back Fabio to the mass singer
ladies and gentlemen some noise for
failure what planet what planet are we
living on okay first of all I'm scarred
by that Fabio hotel because that is a
[ __ ] epic oh I know this was a long
time ago but I hope you made a full
recovery I know it's terrifying
my goodness I also want to take a moment
to very selflessly call out Charlie and
myself for being bad guessers last week
we saw a clue in the white tigers clue
package and it was of this poster of a
cow skiing and so Charlie and I are
sitting here we're like is is Gronk into
winter sports has he gone to the X Games
listen I even googled if Gronk has
purchased cattle before and/or worked on
a cattle farm like we were taking this
to every extreme that we possibly could
well quite literally it's just a cow
skiing hausky you guys certainly told us
online we saw it on Twitter as well so
thank you for pointing that out because
we certainly missed a big one here with
that poster we sure did now I think it
is officially time it is officially time
for us to introduce our new segment the
masked singer ringer where we're gonna
be calling celebrities or expert
panelists who might be able to shed some
insight on what it is these characters
are doing on the show this week we're
doing one better
we actually got someone in studio ladies
and gentlemen dr. Drew Pinsky show I
want to celebrate it yeah everybody you
guys are brutal with sure you they don't
take it that seriously oh we do of
course you were the eagle last season
you've got all the expert Intel and
inside I had a LaBelle kicked my butt so
much better about this year that whole
Smackdown deal was not good because if
you lost once you're probably going home
yeah right so you're appreciating this
whole well I mean like really great oh
that picture yeah there you are it was
so fun and you guy was talking about the
six degrees of separation one of the
reasons I did it is I've known Ken
before anybody knew Ken how he was a
physician he used to sit on my shoulders
right yes
and Janney I've known she's a single
file followed love line and to be back
in the 90s I've known her that long and
both of them that when when they were
you miss a lot of the interaction with
the judges they hit it a lot of it goes
on for quite a while tell us what we've
met and in my thing can goes at one
point he goes I know exactly who you are
yeah you have a talk show I used to sit
in for you I thought oh my god he's got
it he goes you're Craig Ferguson and
then Jenny got all the way to Adam
Carolla and that's why I have that funny
look on my face with a mascot because
like you can't get one step could
imagine it was me well I surely we
didn't guess you either it was very
shocking and surprising in the coolest
way possible
that was the idea to screw with those
guys and everybody it was funny we also
don't see Robin Thicke he was very kind
to me and so was Nicole but when I took
the mask off he says I just didn't see
that coming but that's part of the game
right that was what's fun about is
people that you've never heard sing
before hide behind a mask take on a
character yeah that's the other part you
don't know when you put those masks on
that character carries you and I told
you before the show started that I
thought it was gonna be like an American
Eagle so I was learning anthems
absolutely and then I put the thing on
it I thought oh my god it's a rock Eagle
have to learn rock songs which I can't
sing but here goes because that that
costume demanded it rock songs did you
learn any project oh I was working on
its Queen and the next song I was gonna
sing was Def Leppard in fact and we've
if I had gotten through I was kind of in
a panic about I thought that's not a
good second song but here we go
I think you did such a tremendous job
and obviously we have some more
questions about your experience on the
show but I want to ask you about this
current season I know you watched it
with us earlier tonight you're very
vested in it invested that the whole
community around the show they if
excellent producers and they're putting
on a the massiveness of this production
and they all the different and keeping
it secret and all the different songs
and music directions so many layers and
choreography and fireworks it's a model
past oh my god
so you
hurt our guesses yes what do you think
like you want to start with you want to
start with the turtle well I agree with
you on that I really don't know that
very well would you you guys fit all
those pieces together
however on Chaka Khan you missed that
the deep ditch piece deep-dish pizza so
all three things up there were for
Chicago that's the thing with the show
is that the clues can look like they
belonged to Charlie but then they could
also be very easily applicable to you
you know what I mean you interpret it
however yes okay so you see a shortcut
and now grunt house key do you agree
with that still think I'm hung up on
that skiing cow I gotta figure a team
that they beat herself me trust me
Charlie was literally investigating
everything with cattle and robber and
cows key connection other than literally
cows key so I picked up if you notice
when they push the quarter across the
table he's wearing one of those big
styrofoam number one and it's orange
like Florida yeah and I don't know if
they were number one when Gaga she was
playing there I imagine they were so
that's interesting and look his right
size for Gronkowski voice doesn't really
sound like Gronkowski but he could be I
think you know I'm not even really
listening to the voice really and I
think they're I think you people and
people like you have the producers
paying more attention in the clues now
well they're a little haphazard when I
was doing it they would sort of make a
little narrative out of it and they
didn't really it was true or not it
really matter what did you think of your
own clues when you thought I thought
there were they were okay but they
emphasize things I'm like it's not
really that happened but I'm not
suddenly gonna be off on a motorcycle as
a rock star oh you're very kind but then
then you also missed for what's-her-name
kangaroo yeah okay do you think it's
Jordan what I think that's a great guess
and the the boom with the airplane when
you do a boom interview and reality show
it's called it OTF on the fly maybe that
airplane is
just to make you think no they're not
there see everything has so many double
triple meaning yeah they leave it wide
open for you to interpret I love that um
having done the show I'm curious like
looking back do you have a favorite
memory or a moment or is there something
you can share with us that we didn't see
on TV well a lot of the stuff that you
didn't see on TV was with the judges
also of there's a little bit arresting
Tibbett for you I was doing they they
were like like they wanted to be me to
be wild wild they were like come on come
on okay but so I was doing a lot of this
out there and they noticed they cut that
out I think that's my own family family
and so I was doing a lot of crazy
movements that that Robin Thicke really
liked I made several comments about they
didn't seem so isn't that interest wow
they cut your rock on I thought it but
maybe double horn its and to be fair
it's a show for everybody right that's
supposed to be that why should I should
have thought of that but but okay so now
I have to ask obviously it's a secret
who the other celebrities are on the
show did you have any guesses to the
other voices are here no when I was on
when you were on no they you don't even
hear it you don't get you don't get to
see what's going on I heard Patti
LaBelle I didn't know his pattern the
bill but I heard my competition because
I was backstage being sort of led around
getting ready to come on but that was
the only singing I heard the entire time
I was there
they look they've heard how they hide
you to hide you right they put gloves on
not nothing on a speck of skin show
you're not allowed to speak and they
call you by your character name yeah and
they talk to me to this day because you
get pretty close with these people it's
a pretty intense environment and my
producers still call me to this day and
call me eagle but not the designing but
but they call you early in the process
and say you know you have any thoughts
and I and I just deferred to them and I
forget what the other two things were
they presented to me but they presented
an eagle and that's what I had in my
head when I came to them I thought the
American Eagle be awesome Wow and like I
said then I learned all those anthems
that I had to unlearn and oh I had all
kinds of pride a vocal injury yeah
whole mess going on ride to see it an
ear nose and throat get repeated
laryngoscopy a coat a vocal coach and
they make you sign a very strict
non-disclosure I'm sure so we were due I
was training at home and when my son's
was living at home at the time and this
vocal cord started showing up he's like
hey what's that all about I'm gonna sing
at a hockey game but then she starts
showing up like three times a week ago
what's this about right listen I think
it was such a treat to have you on the
show and of course people who have been
to sporting events we've heard you sing
the national anthem but to see you
singing rock songs was so incredible can
I put you on the spot for a second well
you said you learned pour some sugar on
me oh my god I'll tell you what I was
learning a lot of October I was learning
a lot of was a lot of I thought we were
gonna go towards anthems and Michael
Buble and Frank Sinatra come fly with me
let's fly away oh that's sort of the
direction we were going I love it
trashed all of it and went for the rags
rock songs I do want to ask are you
putting out any music no okay so me
plans no plans I I do did somebody told
me that there might be a tour with this
would you consider joining I think it'd
be just because I loved the whole
operation so much of even I'd consider
and I would love to come back and be a
judge come on guys former performers up
let's get that petition going and of
course I just have to ask before we
leave I know you have a movie coming out
yes yes tell us about it
it's I'm treating a guy who has a wild
life I'm his doctor
and he won't come clean to me what he's
doing because what he's doing is awful
Wow
so and I'm trying to get him take some
medication because his life is out of
control
Wow are you enjoying the acting process
it was yeah it's really fun it's really
a blast I mean I anytime somebody wants
me to do that show up and be myself yeah
it's it's hard work it was such a treat
to have you here with us tonight we want
to keep in touch with you you got to let
us know where your jet where your guests
are off of your guys off your heels I'm
gonna see what your doors are yeah yeah
keep up with us right here on I'm asking
the best singer we'll keep you in the
loop
as always thank you guys so much for
joining us let us know who you think is
borrowing these crazy costumes thank you
so much to dr. drew Charlie O'Keefe
Deidre Behar we'll see you next time
guys
[Music]